Now, in a world where basically that's all you do is you create demand on the left side of the funnel
and somebody purchases on the right, you could kind of like measure how much it cost to do that
and then we'll talk about customer acquisition cost a little later, but there's a little magic accelerator
on the bottom of this funnel, and that's called the viral loop.
A viral loop could be something as simple as somebody bought one of your products in the store
and could not wait to tell their friends--wow, this was the greatest thing ever,
you can't wait to get them boom.
You now have kind of a magnifying effect, a viral effect,
about selling your product based on users loving it.
Well, this happened for a hundreds of years, but now we could sometimes engineer this viral loop
by saying--is there anything that we can do, any incentives, any ways to kind of get rebates,
is there a way to turn our customers into sales people to kind of accelerate this purchase
to help us get new customers.
And Smart Startups think about this loop all the time, so viral loops are something
that startups want to see if it's possible to create.
Now, just don't feel bad if in your company it's really not possible to do viral--
for example, in dating sites.
Not everybody wants to announce to their friends that they are actually visiting a dating site.
So in some cases it might not be possible, but in other you should always keep your eye out--
is it possible to make this funnel more efficient.